recently there has been potentially very
exciting news from the Large Hadron
Collider the Large Hadron Collider is
quoted as the largest machine ever built
by human beings just outside of Geneva
Switzerland it collides two beams of
protons the collisions are the highest
energy ever produced by humans and ever
recorded and that data allows us to
probe in essence the structure of matter
and of space-time itself the Large
Hadron Collider started up operations
last year again after a long shutdown
and is running at almost twice the
energy it was before in the first run
the collider discovered the Higgs boson
which is the last particle of the
standard model and a key piece of
understanding how matter was created in
the early universe and exists today what
has been seen now in the new data is
potentially a particle that has no room
to fit in the standard model it would be
something that up ends the standard
model of particle physics and so
physicists all over the place are very
excited that we may be on the verge of
seeing something big the particle decays
if it's true into two photons what's
actually seen in the collider are two
particles of light coming out at an
energy at roughly 6 times the energy of
the Higgs boson so it implies the
existence of a new particle which is 6
times as heavy as the Higgs is brand-new
and we don't know what it is to see
something totally random is incredibly
exciting that's when the fun begins you
don't know what it's going to be and
sorry so that's where we are right now
it could easily go away July comes where
we got more day that's not really there
it was a random fluctuation that happens
all the time this one is a little bit
more exciting than most because the
signal was stronger than usual and
theoretically to explain it it's
actually very simple which makes you
think
maybe this is more plausible keep an eye
on the science news right here in fact
in the summer and you'll find out as we
do if there's anything to be really
excited about